let's go next to our caller from the
five-one-six-- area code who's calling
today from five one six hey David it's
me John from Long Island New York
hey Johnny how you doing how's the
vacation vacation was great I was really
good love that I'm just calling cuz I'm
I'm just wondering why how come
politicians don't I feel like
politicians don't really run on trying
to make like America like make a lot of
money in terms of like like we could
benefit from having a surplus of energy
if we had more solar power panels and
more wind turbines and had the ability
to store all this electrical energy and
we could sell it to other countries like
how come we don't really do something
like that or even like just get in the
horse business like owning a lot of
horses getting for the horse market John
you're not hitting your phone with a
hammer are you no I'm sorry you're not
on speaker um it's a little raining out
here got it maybe it's raindrops hitting
the phone listen the horse Mart you
you're saying that the US should get
should buy a bunch of horses or or breed
them and then sell them to WHO I mean
not really specifically horses but I'm
just saying cuz Turkmenistan they they
have a lot of horses and I believe they
somewhat have a good stake in the horse
market maybe but what I'm really trying
to say is yeah Russia and China they're
like China specifically they're doing a
lot of solar panels they're making a lot
of electricity and at one point they
could have a surplus when you have a
surplus of energy you can profit off
that much more so right now today in
America the most employed most employers
are from Walmart and Amazon and that's
not really we can't really make money
off a Walmart based economy do you know
what I'm saying right now yeah it's you
know you're saying a lot of different
things and I'm doing the best I can to
parse it but just because of that
hammering on the phone I'm gonna think
about this one offline and then follow
up and I'm gonna I'm gonna let you go
for now but I really appreciate you
laying out your perspective all right
I'm sorry David no I'll talk to you
again soon all right John from Long
Island very very good to hear from you